So I'm going to start with where we're at now.
So when I started as staff at Cleveland Clinic, we didn't even have Andromedon.
We were giving everyone Cyborg D, and then Andromedon got approved.
So Andromedon will take about half to 60% of patients and put them where we want amyloid
patients to be, hematologic CR.
But you'll note there that that median time to achieving that goal is a little over two
months.
When we look at the data that's out there in the real world for using BCMA, bispecific
antibody of your choice, it is a drastically improved outcome.
So using this real-world data, we're seeing near 100%, 98% to 100% response rates.
There's a very favorable safety profile in these patients.
It's all relapsed refractory, AL.
Patients that are having real-world data, reports coming out from Mayo, the consortium,
our own internal data.
And then we're going to publish our data.
We'll combine with Tufts.
The time to the first hematologic response with any of the BCMA bispecifics is 0.6 months.
The best outcome in these patients occur in really three settings.
Early disease detection, rapidly achieving complete hematologic remission, shutting down
new amyloid production, and then in the kappa only patients, being able to get access to
a viral monoclonal.
So some work to be done there with the macrophage activating in the antifibril antibody space.
But right now, these two things are achievable.
So our real-world data, this is 20 patients within our center.
19 of the patients do have efficacy and safety data.
One of the patients passed during ramp-up, so we don't, unfortunately, have any sort
of long-term outcomes on that patient.
We have 100% overall response rate with 100% of them achieving a rapid hematologic CR.
The median time within our patient subset.
It was 0.5.
And you see that range is very tight.
So when you look at any other drug in amyloid, you don't see numbers anywhere close to this.
The timing, again, of that median time to achieving a hematologic CR, 0.6.
Again, a very tight range around that window.
The median progression-free survival, median duration are not achieved.
But I do have outcomes on several patients that are 24-plus months.
And what's even more impressive is within our own dataset.
Some of us were given continuous BCMA.
And some of us started using a very short, limited duration of four to six months.
The 24-plus-month patients all received fixed duration.
They have not had any evidence of disease returning.
So these are the current studies that are on clinicaltrials.gov.
So these are all investigator-initiated studies looking at the relapse refractory setting.
There are also studies coming out from every player in the space.
So we have Pfizer in the game, J&J, AbbVie, Regeneron.
And now we have our first studies that are being pharma-sponsored coming out in amyloid,
looking at relapse refractory use with BCMA.
So the race is really on, and in particular, looking at these agents
at upfront newly-diagnosed amyloid.
So these are the studies that have actually opened in newly-diagnosed amyloid.
So there's one with teclistamab.
They're enrolling 25 patients.
It's going to be a six-month fixed duration.
There's another study looking at actually Mayo Stage 3B patients.
So the patients that traditionally could have higher risk or a little more fear,
but really the patients that probably would benefit the most from this drug class.
They're enrolling 35 patients, and they're looking at a different outcome instead
of the other one.
So these are the studies that have actually opened in newly-diagnosed amyloid.
So there's one with teclistamab. They're enrolling 25 patients.
It's going to be a six-month fixed duration. There's another study looking at actually Mayo Stage 3B patients.
of the hematologic CR, they're looking at assessing a one-month reduction in the difference in the
free light chains. The current issues that exist within all of the newly diagnosed AL studies is
most of these patients, they don't live near an academic medical center. They're offering trials
in AL. So this is leading to slower recruitment to current studies. They're not allowing any prior
AL treatment. There's a very complicated schedule when you're doing combinations. So if you look
back at this top study, it's a combination with daratumumab. So there's going to be some more
kind of hurdles to overcome with getting these patients to a site that can give access to the
drug that's going to cure the majority of AL amyloid patients. The single agent, I think,
is going to be enough. We have tons of real-world data in that relapsed refractory setting.
The DARA, this is going to be controversial to say, but it's unlikely to add any efficacy here.
It may, in fact, actually add to more infections and more complicated dosing schedule for patients.
The clone in AL is very different. It's ubiquitously positive for BCMA expression.
It's a much lower clone. I don't think many of us are as worried about our T-cell fitness.
We're just going to obliterate the clone safely and allow these patients to live their life.
There's also too long of a duration of these study interventions, so two years versus six months.
So this is...
This is the design that we are going to be going forward with as a research collaboration.
So we're going to randomize a total of 64 patients, so 32 per arm,
and it's looking at a dose strategy for scheduling. So is every two weeks or every four weeks?
Which of these is going to be able to provide enough of a quick reduction after step-up dosing?
And so the point of all of this is looking at all of our...
Our real-world data and having patients achieve a rapid hematologic response within 0.6,
that covers the step-up dosing window, and then one additional full dose after step-up.
That should get patients where they need to be, and within our own internal data set,
within the consortium data set, there are lots of patients who are receiving every four-week dosing.
That will allow these patients to be traveling further distances to come to get...
Treatment with us.
We could see a world, even as early as a couple years from now, where patients are coming,
getting two step-up doses, another full dose, and then four more monthly doses in their care.